[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING] [CLICKING]
CASEY RODRIGUEZ: So last
time we spoke about--
we covered sets and induction.
This time, I want to ask
a question about sets,
which turns out is actually
quite a deep question.
I mean, I didn't come
up with it myself.
This question is at least
150 years old probably.
So the question that I want to
ask is if A and B are sets--
or let's phrase it this
way, at least a little more
efficiently.
When do two sets, A and
B, have the same size?
Now, this is
especially interesting
if these two sets
are not finite,
meaning there's
not five of them,
there's not eight of them,
but there's infinitely
many members,
whatever that means.
And I'll actually
define what that means.
For example, do the natural
numbers and the integers
have the same size?
Do the natural numbers
and the rational numbers
have the same size?
What about the rational
numbers and the real numbers?
Even though we haven't
defined that yet,
you can still keep in mind
your notion of the real numbers
from calculus.
And so this question is--
why is it deep?
Because it depends
on this word here,
"size," and what
exactly that means.
So I'm not-- so
kind of an answer,
this is due to George Cantor.
He said that two sets--
so not an answer, but
a way of defining size
or a way of saying the two
sets have the same size.
He said two sets have the
same size when the two sets--
the elements of the two sets
can be paired off, meaning--
and I will make this much more
precise in a minute or so.
What does he mean?
Or what do I mean?
For example, the set a, b,
and c and the set 1, 2, and 3.
So this one, this set, consists
of three letters-- a, b, and c.
This set consists
of three integers--
1, 2, and 3.
They have the same size
because I can essentially
pair them off.
So a and 1 go together,
b and 2 go together,
and c and 3 go together,
meaning each member of this set
gets paired off with
an element of this set.
And every element of
this set gets paired off
with a unique element
from this set.
Now, to make-- and so
this goes under the name
of the theory of cardinality or
cardinal numbers, if you like.
But we won't go
too deeply into it.
So the way you make--
or the way one makes
this pairing off business
more precise is using the
language of functions.
And you've been dealing
with functions since you've
been doing calculus.
So I'm just going to quickly
reintroduce or review
some terminology that goes
along with functions that
will be the precise meaning
of this pairing off business
that I'm writing here.
But just with an eye
towards the future,
this is why I'm reviewing some
of this terminology related
to functions.
So a brief review of some
terminology for functions--
so let me just recall
that if A and B are sets,
then function f A B--
so a function's usually written
as f colon A arrow to B,
meaning it takes elements
from A into elements from B.
This is a mapping that--
or if you like, an assignment.
It assigns to each x in
A a unique element which
we denote f of x in B.
So one single input, x,
gives me a single output.
And the input does not
give me three outputs.
Now, this is what one would call
a naive definition probably,
not necessarily
completely unambiguous.
But for us, it suffices.
In the textbook, you
can look up a function
is unambiguously defined or as a
subset of the Cartesian product
of A and B, which
you would recognize
as essentially describing
the graph of the function.
But then you never use
that definition of again.
And you essentially
use this definition
when you think about
functions and when you
prove properties of function.
So this we will just
take as our definition.
And it will be
unambiguous enough for us.
So let f be a
function from A to B.
If C is a subset of
A, we define a set--
so this is f of capital C.
So C is not an element of A.
It's a subset of A.
And this is a subset
of B. This is--
let me write it slightly
differently here.
This is a set of all
y in B such that there
exists an x in C such
that y equals to f of x.
And I could write this a
little more efficiently as this
is the set of all
elements f of x
as x ranges over the
elements of this subset C.
And if D is a subset of B, we
define the set f inverse of D.
This is the set of guys
that get mapped into D.
So I should say this is
the inverse image of D,
not the inverse of
this function f.
So the inverse, whatever
that means for now,
does not necessarily
always exist.
So this inverse image of
the set D always exists.
This is the set of all elements
in A such that f of x is in D.
So for example, let me--
so 1, 2, 3, 4 and a, b, c, d.
And let's suppose 1 goes
to a, 2 goes to a, 3 goes
to c, 4 goes to d.
Then f of the set 1,
2, this is where--
what is the set that gets--
so this is the subset of--
so this you should think of as
B, a, b, and c, and D. And then
1, 2, and 3, this is A.
So f of the set of 1, 2--
so 1 gets mapped to a.
2 gets mapped to a.
So this is just the set 2.
f of the set--
let's go with 1 and 3.
1 gets mapped to a.
So this should be a.
And 3 gets mapped
gets mapped to c.
And so a couple of
inverse images--
if I look at the
inverse image of a,
this is equal to the set
of all guys that map to a.
This is, well, 1 maps
to a and 2 maps to a.
So this is 1, 2.
Now, if I look at the
inverse image of a,
c, d, what elements get
mapped to a, c, and d?
Well, 1 and 2 get mapped to a.
3 gets map to c.
4 gets mapped to d.
So everything maps
into a, C, and d.
So this is just the
original set or the set A--
1, 2, 3, 4.
All right, so there's
more terminology.
And this is what we
will mean by when
two sets can be paired off.
Or this makes that more precise.
Let f be a function from A to
B. We say that f is injective,
or I'll write one-to-one.
It should be read
one-to-one if f satisfies
the following property.
f of x1 equals f of x2
implies x1 equals x2.
So injective, or
one-to-one, means
if I take two different inputs,
I get two different outputs.
That's essentially
what this means.
I mean, taking the equivalent--
so equivalently, from
a logical standpoint,
this statement
implying this statement
is equivalent to the
negation of this statement
implying the negation
of this statement.
So equivalently, this means x
not equal to x2 implies f of x1
not equal to f of x2.
So maybe this is clear.
If I were to define f as
injective if it satisfies
this property, maybe
that would have
been clearer that f takes
two different elements to two
different elements.
But this condition here is
typically easier to verify,
or at least simpler
to state and verify.
So f is surjective or
onto if the image of A
is B. So let me write that
statement out a little bit
more.
Everything in the set B gets
mapped to by something from A.
So equivalently, this
says that for all y in B
there exists an x in A
so that f of x equals y.
f is bijective if f is
one-to-one and onto.
So f is bijective if it's
both injective and surjective.
So for example, this map
that we just drew over here
that sends 1 to a, 2 to b--
I mean 2 to a, 3
to c, 4, to d, this
is neither injective
nor surjective.
It's not injective because it
takes two different elements
to the image in B, namely a.
So it takes 1 and 2 to a.
It's not surjective
because nothing gets
mapped to the element b here.
So we've seen that's
not surjective.
Of course, this map, if I take--
again, imagine this
is 1, 2, 3 a, b, c, d.
This map here, this function
here that takes 1 to a, 2
to b, 3, to c, this is actually
injective but not surjective.
And then of course, we
could change this slightly.
And 1 goes to a, 2 goes
to b, and 3 goes to b.
Then this is surjective
but not injective.
Now, the map that sends--
let's switch sides here--
a, b, and c, 1, 2, 3--
a to 1, b to 2, c to 3, this
is a bijection, bijective.
So if I say something's
an injection or surjection
or bijection, that just means
it's a map that is injective,
or, surjective or
bijective respectively.
And now, a definition--
so this is really--
there's not much
to this definition,
but just defining a couple
of related functions
that are related to
a given function.
If f goes from A to
B, g goes from B to C,
the composition g of f is the
function which goes from A to C
is defined by g of f of
x equals g of f of x.
And 2, if f is bijective--
so this is the composition
of two functions.
I didn't write the word
composition, but g of f
means the composition, or is
referred to as a composition.
If f is bijective, then we
define the inverse function
to f, B to A, by the following.
If y is in B, then
f inverse of y in A
is the unique elements in A such
that if I take this element,
stick it into f, I get back y.
So the inverse of a
function only exists
for bijective
functions, or at least
is only defined for
bijective functions.
Keep that in mind.
Don't confuse that with
the inverse image of sets.
Although, those two
notations look the same.
You have an inverse
f to the minus 1.
f to the minus 1,
if it's a function,
that is the inverse function.
However, if I'm taking f
to the minus 1 of a set,
that means the inverse image of
that set as defined over there.
So bijections, meaning
bijective functions,
will be what we mean when we
say two sets can be paired off.
It's what we mean when we--
or at least what Cantor's
answer to that original question
was, when did two sets
have the same size.
So this is the notion of
cardinality that I alluded to.
So we say two
sets, A and B, have
the same cardinality
if there exists
a bijection or a bijective
function f from A to B.
And so let me just make some
notation here. so this is not
really new objects I'm
defining or operations.
This is just some notation.
So when two sets have the
same cardinality, we write--
so this is just a shorthand way
of writing that two functions
have the same cardinality.
You should not necessarily
think this means taking
the absolute value of a set.
That doesn't mean
anything, all right?
This is just shorthand
notation for saying two
sets have the same cardinality.
If A has the same cardinality
as the set 1, 2, 3 up to n,
we write A equals n.
That's just shorthand
for saying that a set has
the same cardinality as the
natural numbers up to n.
So if there exists an
injective function-- or I
will often say either
function or map.
You should take
those as synonymous.
There exists an
injective function f--
if there exists an injective
function f from A to B,
we write this thing.
Again, do not read this as
taking the absolute value
of some set and
that absolute value
is less than or equal to the
absolute value of the other set
because that's meaningless.
We haven't said what
that means even.
This is just shorthand notation.
And if there exists an
injection from A to B
but they don't have the same
cardinality, we write this.
So even though this notation
of these absolute value
things being on the
outside of the set
makes you think absolute
value or should be interpreted
as absolute value,
it's OK to think
as a certain
ordering being there,
as A having smaller size than B.
We write this because there
being an injection from one
set to the other means I
can pair off elements of A
with some elements
of B. Maybe I don't
get all of the elements
of B. But I can pair off
some of the elements of A with
some of the elements of B.
For example, that first
map we wrote up there,
that says that the
set 1, 2, 3 in size
is less than or equal
to the size of a, b, c,
d because we found an
injection, an injective map
from the first set
to the second set.
This third map would say that
the size of the set a, b,c is
equal to 3, written here,
or shorthand written here.
And in fact, that first map that
we wrote up there, again, is--
so from first map, this says
that the set of 1, 2, 3--
in our shorthand
notation, absolute value
is less than the
size of a, b, c, d.
So don't think of these as
saying the absolute value.
It's best to maybe think of
this as saying the size of.
All right, so if there exists
an injective map or function
from one set to another,
then the size of A
is less than or equal to the
size of B. If the size of A
is less than or equal
to the size of B
but the size of A and
B are not the same,
we write the size of A is
less than the size of B.
So best to think of those--
this absolute
value looking thing
as being shorthand for
saying the words size of.
Now, I'm not going
to prove this.
It goes a little bit beyond
the scope of this class.
But let me just say that this
ordering, this inequality,
these symbols that
we're writing does
bear some sort of semblance to
the ordering of real numbers
in that if I have two real
numbers, one is less than
or equal to the
other and vice versa.
So A is less than or equal
to B and B is less than
or equal to A, then
A must equal B.
That is, in fact, true also
for this elementary notion
of size of sets.
And this is--
I mean, it shouldn't
surprise you for finite sets
necessarily.
If I have a pairing of A, if
A is no bigger than n and n is
no bigger than the size of A,
then a should have n elements.
But it takes a little
bit more to prove
for sets which are not finite.
So I forgot to write this down.
We also say that
if the size of A
is equal to the size of
this finite set 1 through n,
we say A is finite.
So this theorem that
I'm stating here
is the Cantor Schroeder
Bernstein theorem,
which states that
if the size of A
is less than or equal to the
size of B and the size of B
size of A, then the size of A
equals the size of B. So again,
if you're thinking of these
in the context of real
numbers, one being less than
or equal to the
other and vice versa,
of course, that implies that
those two real numbers are
equal to each other.
But we're not talking
about real numbers.
Again, this is just
shorthand notation
for saying there exists a
bijective map from A to B. This
means there exists a bijective
map from A to the set.
This means there exists an
injective map from A into this,
from a to this set.
So this is not a statement
about real numbers.
This is a statement about
cardinality, all right?
OK.
So finite sets are sets that you
can count if you had n fingers.
Now, we would like to be
able to define what it means
to be able to count a set.
So what do I mean
by count a set?
Meaning, if I had
infinite time, I
could go through the
set counting them--
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7,
8, 9, 10 and so on.
I don't need to go anymore.
But what does that
process of counting mean?
That means, for each
element of the set
that I'm trying to
count, I can pair it off
with a natural number--
1, 2, 3, and so on.
So this is how we
define countable sets.
So if A has the same size
as the natural numbers,
meaning there exists a bijection
from A to the natural numbers,
then we say A is
countably infinite.
If A is finite, or countably--
I also use a lot of shorthand,
but it's not clever shorthand.
So you should just be
able to sound what--
if you just sound that out,
you'll get what word I mean,
countably, countably infinite.
We say A is countable.
So countably infinite means I
need all the natural numbers
to be able to count off
the elements of the set A.
Countable means maybe
I stop after some point
and I've counted all them.
So A is finite or it's
countably infinite.
Otherwise, if a set
is not countable,
we say it's uncountable.
OK, so let's take a look at
a couple of countable sets
that maybe don't come
off as being countable.
The set of-- actually,
that's a homework problem.
The set of even
integers is countable.
The set of odd-- so I said
integers a minute ago.
Maybe I should just
say natural numbers.
The set of odd natural
numbers is countable.
So in fact-- so this
is just an aside.
So these are two
disjoint subsets
that make up the
natural numbers, even
and odd natural numbers.
And they both have the same size
as the set that they make up.
So it's almost like
saying the cardinality
of the natural numbers
is twice the cardinality
of the natural numbers,
since you would think
that the size of N should
be the size of this set
plus the size of this set,
since they are disjoint
and they make up the set.
But that's not how
cardinality works.
You don't just add cardinalities
to get the cardinalities.
So this is a subtle, interesting
thing about cardinalities
So Richard Feynman,
who won the Nobel Prize
in the '60s for his work
on QED, described this
as saying there are twice
as many numbers as numbers.
OK, so let's prove this.
So what does this mean?
This means we have to be able
to find a bijective function
from this set to this set or
from this set to this set, one
or the other.
And so in fact, maybe I should--
well, I'll say something
about that in a minute.
Well, let me pause.
Let me pause this
just for a minute.
And let me make a few
comments about cardinality,
which maybe I should have.
So this you can think
of as a little theorem.
If I have two sets, A
has the same size as B,
then B has the same size
as A. So remember, I mean,
what I just said in
English is not exactly
what those symbols mean.
Remember, this means there
exists a bijection from A to B
This means there exists
a bijection from B to A.
So what is the proof
of this statement?
So let's start off
with the hypothesis.
Suppose then there
exists a bijective map,
bijective function
f from A to B.
Now, if I have a bijection
from A to B, then
what would be a bijection
going from B to A?
That would just be the inverse.
So this is not the
inverse image of sets,
like we described, but
the actual inverse,
which we defined over there.
Is a bijection.
So B has the same size as A.
One other statement-- so if A
and B have the same size and B
and C have the same size--
so again, A, B, and C are sets.
I should have written
that at the beginning.
But from this context,
you should understand
that A, B, and C are sets--
then A and C have the same size.
So let's do a proof of that.
So let's start with
the hypothesis,
meaning A has the same size as
B and B has the same size as C.
So what did these
two statements mean
in terms of the definition?
That means there exists
a bijection from A to B
and a bijection from B to
C. And this statement-- so
let me finish this.
And then I'll say what
I was going to say.
Then there exists bijections f
from A to B and g from B to C.
So perhaps I should have
said a few more words
about why this is true.
But I'm going to leave
this as an exercise
just to pause the lecture
and do it yourself.
And what I'll write shortly--
for this case,
I'll actually prove
that the thing I'm going
to define is bijection.
That should help you.
So let me draw over
here off to the side.
We have, again,
1, 2, 3, a, b, c.
So think of this as f.
This is my set A.
This is my set B.
And then I have
alpha, beta, gamma.
And a gets mapped to alpha,
b, gets mapped to beta,
c gets mapped to gamma.
So what would be the map going
from A down to the set C?
Well, perhaps the composition.
1 gets mapped to a, which
gets mapped to alpha.
So 1 gets mapped to alpha.
2 gets mapped to beta.
3 gets mapped to gamma.
How do I build this function
out of the things that I know,
namely this f and g?
Well, this function
going from A to C
is just the composition
of these two functions.
So this is off to the side.
This is not a part of the proof.
Let h go from A to C be
the function g of f of x.
So I claim that this
function is a bijection.
So we want to prove that it's
one-to-one and onto, all right?
So let's do one-to-one first.
So we this is the
part where I'm going
to put this in parentheses,
meaning what we're doing now.
So we're going to prove
that h is one-to-one.
So that means we have to
verify the definition that I've
erased.
So remember the definition.
So let's write it all out.
We first show h is one-to-one.
And what this means, according
to the definition that I'm now
writing over, if h of x1 equals
h of x2, then x1 equals x2.
So this is what
we want to prove.
This is the definition
of h being one-to-one.
So let's start.
If h of x1 equals h
of x2, then, in terms
of how we've defined
h, which is g
of f of x, so the composition,
then this means g of f of x1
equals g of f of x2.
That's just what h is.
Now, this statement here--
now g we know is a bijection.
We know g is one-to-one.
And since g of something equals
g of something else and g
is one-to-one, this implies
that f of x1 equals f of x2.
This is since g is one-to-one.
So starting with this
and the definition of h
being the composition,
we conclude that f of x1
has to equal f of x2
because g is one-to-one.
Now, since f is
also one-to-one--
we are assuming that f
and g are bijections.
Since f is one-to-one,
this implies x1 equals x2,
since f is one-to-one.
And this is what
we wanted to prove.
We wanted to start with
assuming h of x1 equals h of x2
and prove x1 equals x2,
which is what we've done.
So thus, we've proven
that h is one-to-one.
Now, we have to show that it's
surjective, that it's onto.
h of A equals C. And again,
I'll write out what this means.
This means for all y in C--
all right, let me
call it [? z-- ?]
there exists an x in A
such that h of x equals z.
Now, we used the
fact that f and g
were injective to conclude that
the composition is injective.
So it stands to
reason that we're
going to use the fact that
they're both surjective
to prove that h is surjective.
So we need to prove
that for all z in C
there exists an x in A as
such that h of x equals z.
So let z be in C. Now,
we need to find some
x in A that gets mapped to z.
We'll use that g and
f are both surjective.
And what's the picture
that goes along with this?
Here's the sets C, B, and
A. We have some element of z
And we know that
since g is surjective,
there's some element in B
that gets mapped to z by G.
But now, since f going
from A to B is surjective,
there exists some
x which maps to y.
And then that's
the whole argument.
That's it.
I drew this picture.
But now, I just need
to turn it into English
using the properties and
assumptions that I have.
Since g is surjective, there
exist a y in B such that g of y
equals z.
Since f is surjective, there
exists an x in A so that f of x
equals y.
But then if I look
at h of x, this
is equal to g of f of x,
which is equal to g of y,
which is equal to z by
how we've defined y.
Remember, g of y equals z, how
we found y and how we found x.
Remember, f of x equals this y.
And therefore,
this map h is onto.
And therefore, h is a
bijection, proving this theorem.
So that should help you.
I'll give you many
exercises to prove
that the inverse of a
bijection is a bijection.
So back to what we were
doing to begin with.
We want to show the set of
even natural numbers has
the same size as
the natural numbers,
has the same cardinality, as
the natural numbers and the same
for the odd ones.
So I'm just going
to do the odd ones.
Again, this will be a
small exercise for you
to do to prove number 2, the
statement for the odd ones.
So I'm going to
do the even ones.
And you can do the odd ones.
You should, if you plan
on studying more math,
get used to the instructor,
professor, research paper
writer, textbook author
giving out little exercises
to make sure that
you're following along
and that you can do some
minor task at some point
during the discussion.
So we're going to find--
so we want to show that
the natural numbers has
the same size as the even
natural numbers, which
is the same as this statement
by that first theorem I wrote up
there.
Now, that means we need
to find a bijection
from the natural numbers to the
set of even natural numbers.
This should be not too bad.
I mean, so again, this
is off to the side.
This is not part of the proof.
What would be the map going
from these guys to these guys?
Well, I mean, there's
several you could choose.
But maybe the simplest
is 1 gets mapped to 2,
2 gets mapped to 4,
3 gets mapped to 6,
4 gets mapped to 8, 5 to 10,
6 to 12, and so on, and so on.
Now, what is that map?
And now, I'll
continue the proof.
Let f be the function into the
even natural numbers defined
by f of n equals 2 times n.
And so n is a natural number.
So this is just formally writing
the function that takes 1 to 2,
2 to 4, 3 to 6, 4, to
8, and so on, and so on.
I claim f is a bijection.
So I have to show that f
is one-to-one and onto.
So we'll first show
f is one-to-one.
So that means that I have to
assume f of n1 equals f of n2
and conclude that n1 equals n2.
So let me actually write out
what this means again for you
to say that f is one-to-one.
Is one to one-- i.e.
if f of n1 equals f of
n2, then n1 equals n2.
But this is easy to
verify for this function
that we've written down because
if f of n1 equals f of n2-- so
remember, this is what we
want to show, all right?
So to show it, I start
with my assumption.
And I need to
conclude n1 equals n2.
So suppose f of
n1 equals f of n2,
my assumption, my hypothesis.
And I need to
conclude n1 equals n2.
Then this implies, by
the definition of f,
2 times n2 equals
2 times n2, which,
by algebra of just eliminating
the 2's, n1 equals n2, which
is the conclusion that I want.
So I've proven the statement
that if f of n1 equals f of n2,
then n1 equals n2.
Therefore, f is one-to-one.
So thus, f is one-to-one.
So now, we want to show
f is onto, surjective.
I'll write this out again. i.e.
For all elements that
n are an even number,
there exists an n such
that f of n equals m.
Now, let m be an even integer.
And so not to confuse us,
let me write 2 times k.
This is the same set.
I'm just using a different
dummy variable instead of n
in my description of the
even natural numbers.
And let's do that here as well.
Again, this is not
changing anything.
This is just changing
the letter I'm
using to describe the set,
which is inconsequential.
But I don't want you to get the
false impression that somehow
I'm not doing anything at all.
OK, so suppose I have an even
integer, then there exists--
simply by the
definition of this set,
there exists an n natural number
so that m equals 2 times n.
Then f of this natural number,
which is 2 times n, equals m.
And therefore, I get
something that maps to m.
Therefore, f is onto.
Therefore, f is a
bijection and the two sets
have the same cardinality.
All right, so let's--
where are we at?
Where should I write?
Let's write here.
Maybe I'll leave that up
because I don't want to--
now, using this-- and
I'll probably put this
in the homework--
I mean, one can also show--
I should say using
this, but one can also
show that the integers
have the same size
as the natural numbers,
which, again, is a little bit
surprising since the
natural numbers are
a strict subset of Z.
So what's the proof?
So I'm going to
draw a picture, then
I'm going to write
down the function,
and then I'm going
to leave it as--
actually, I'm going to put
it in the homework for you
to verify that this function
is one-to-one and onto.
So let's say there's
as many natural numbers
as I want to write and as many
integers as I want to write.
OK, so what would
be a way of mapping
the integers in a
one-to-one and onto fashion
onto the natural numbers?
Well, what we could do--
first off, let's send 0 to 1
just to get 0 out of the way.
And from then on,
now we just need
to find a way to map
the positive integers
and the negative integers onto
the natural numbers bigger
than 2.
And in some way,
mentally, we should
feel like we can do this because
we kind of did it over there,
but not explicitly.
So how about we take 1
to 2, 2 to 4, 3 to 6?
4 would then go to 8.
And we'll take 1
to 3, minus 2 to 5.
I'm getting crossed.
And then minus 3
would get sent to 7.
So you see that the
positive integers
get mapped to the
even natural numbers
and the negative integers
get mapped to the odd natural
numbers bigger than 1.
So I'm not even going
to write the proof.
This will be part
of the homework.
Now, it is a bit surprising
that there are twice
as many numbers as
numbers, not too
surprising since these
subsets, if you picture them
as I've been doing as
subsets of the real line,
you know they're
kind of discrete.
So you should be
able to count them.
What is not-- what is
more surprising are--
is whether or not can count
subsets that, in some sense,
are not discrete.
For example, what about
the rational numbers?
So this is a theorem that--
and let me just look at those
positive rational numbers.
In fact, I could take
all rational numbers.
But for the statement
of this theorem,
if I look at those rational
numbers which are positive,
then this has the same size
as the natural numbers.
You can count the positive
rational numbers, which is just
a bit crazy to me because
here, at least for let's say
the integers, once
I'm at an integer,
I can move to a next biggest one
and count that one in some way,
right?
And so that makes it believable
that I can count the integers.
The integers have the same
size as the natural numbers,
even though that,
at first glance,
it looks like there's
twice as many.
But for rational
numbers, between any two
rational numbers, there's
another rational number
in between them.
You just take the average of
those two rational numbers.
So now, this idea of
being at a rational number
and then moving to the next
big one, you can't do that now.
So now, it's a little bit up in
the air at least whether or not
can count the rational numbers.
And what I'm saying is
that indeed you can.
And this will be
part of the homework.
I will at least give you an
idea of how the proof will
go, what we will actually
be able to write down,
a map based on a simple fact.
So let me not write down proof,
but let me write down a remark.
So we'll actually be able
to write down a map based
on one simple fact, which
is this fundamental theorem
of arithmetic, which says that--
so this is just discussion now.
More stuff will be written
in the homework about this.
So just try to follow along.
So the fundamental
theorem of arithmetic
says that if you have a
positive natural number,
you can write it in a unique way
as a product of prime numbers.
Now, for rational
numbers, using that,
that means you can write
every rational number uniquely
as a product of
prime numbers divided
by another product
of prime numbers
where no two prime numbers--
where the prime numbers up
top and the prime numbers
at the bottom,
none are in common,
meaning you've simplified
as much as possible.
So instead of 15 over 3--
no, that's not good.
Let's say 15 over 30.
You have 1/2.
So the map that I would take--
so what I'm saying here is
that every rational number
can be written as some product.
So let me not use that
notation, but some product p
r1 pN rN q1 s1 qn sM where
p1, p2, and pN, these are all
primes.
q1 up to qN, they're all primes.
r1, rN, these are all exponents,
positive natural numbers.
So rj, sk, these
are natural numbers.
p1 pN q1 to qM are primes.
And for all jk, qj
does not equal pk.
So there's no prime that appears
both up here and down here.
We've already
simplified that away.
So just so you don't
think I'm fooling you,
9/2, which is a positive
rational number,
this is 3 squared over 2, yeah?
I'm not going to do any more.
That's it.
So the map that we will take
from this rational number
to a natural number
will be this gets
mapped to the natural number
p1 to r1, pN to rN times now q1
to 2s 1 minus 1 qM 2Sn minus 1.
So basically, I map
it to the integer that
has this expansion in terms
of prime numbers, where now
the exponents of
these prime numbers
is even depending on
these exponents on top
and the exponents
of this one are odd,
depending on this
exponent on top.
So for example, 3 squared over
2, this would get mapped to 3
to the 4 times 2.
So what we'll do in
the homework is show
that this map is, in
fact, a bijection.
So those two theorems you
will prove in the homework.
They won't be too bad.
I will leave enough hints.
So we've dealt with z.
We've dealt with q, essentially.
I mean, so let me
actually write down--
this is really a corollary
of these two theorems
here, which I haven't
proved, but you
will prove in the homework.
So this says that the
rationals are countable,
all the rationales, not
just the positive ones.
And what's the proof?
So we know that--
so I'm going to
give you a sketch.
Should I sketch it or
should I write it all out?
I'm running a little
bit out of time.
So maybe I will just tell
you why this is true.
I mean, all the details
are essentially here.
I'm just not going to write
it as carefully as I've been
writing down the proofs before.
So let me write this
as the proof sketch.
Of course, you can write these--
you can actually use the
definitions and write this out.
But this is the essential idea.
So we have that the size
of rational numbers--
so let me-- this has the same
size as the rational numbers
which are negative.
And how do we establish this?
Or instead of using
the same letter,
let's say r, since f
of Q equals minus Q
is a bijection from the
first set to the second set.
If I just take a rational
number, positive 1,
take its minus, then I get
an element of the second set.
And this is a bijection.
OK, so thus, since
this has the same size
as the natural numbers,
and by that theorem
we proved over there,
the size of this set
is the same as the
natural numbers--
so it is countable--
then there exists
bijections f going from Q--
so the positive
rational numbers--
to the natural numbers and g
going from the negative ones
to the natural numbers.
So the picture here is--
well, let's not draw
the picture yet.
OK, so I have these
two bijections
from the positive
rationales to the integers--
this one from the
negative rationales
to the natural numbers.
How do I get a map
that goes from all of q
now to the natural numbers?
Well, let's go in between
and go to the integers.
Then I define a function h,
which goes now from all of Q
to the integers by h of
x equals 0 if x equals 0;
equals f of x if x is
positive; and negative g
of x if x is negative.
And h is a bijection.
So everything up
to this point has
been completely fine
with the exception
of me verifying that
this map is a bijection
and this map is a bijection.
So that's the only
parts that I'm
leaving out for you to verify.
Then h is a bijection.
So Q has the same cardinality
as integers, which we've shown
has the same cardinality
as the natural numbers.
And therefore, the rationals
have the same cardinality
as the natural numbers.
So they are countably infinite.
So a natural question is--
I mean, is there anything
bigger than the natural numbers?
Because everything
I've written down,
this has the size of
the natural numbers.
We haven't really defined the
real numbers well enough yet
to make any sort of claim like
that about the real numbers.
And now, is there
just any set that
is bigger in size than
the natural numbers?
The answer to that was unknown.
And it's pretty
strikingly yes, in fact.
So let me phrase that question.
Does there exist a set A
such that A has strictly
bigger cardinality than
the natural numbers, so A
is uncountable?
So to answer this question
astoundingly yes, let me first
define for a general object.
If A is a set, we
define script p of A.
This is the power set of A.
This is a set that consists
of all subsets of A. So this is
a set of all sets B such that B
is a subset of A. So for
example, if A is the empty set,
the power set--
so A is empty.
What are the subsets
of the empty set?
Well, there's only one subset
of the empty set, the empty set.
And even though the
empty set has no members,
its power set has one member.
If A equals 1,
then the power set
of A, the set of all subsets,
consists of the empty set
and the set itself, 1.
And let's do one more.
If A is the set 1, 2,
then the power set of A,
this is the set which
consists of the empty set,
because this is a
subset of this set,
the set consisting of 1, because
this is a subset of this set,
or 2, 1, 2.
Now, notice something.
This set had cardinality.
Strictly speaking, I
should have defined that
as having cardinality 0.
Yet, its power set
has cardinality 1.
A has size 1 because it's
in one-to-one correspondence
with just 1.
And its power set
has two elements.
So it has cardinality 2.
I could count them off--
1, 2.
A has size 2, has two elements.
And the power set
of A has size 4.
It has four different elements--
the empty set, 1, 2, 1, 2.
So what one can prove in
general and which will appear
on the homework is
if A has size n--
so it's a finite set of size
n, meaning it's in one-to-one
correspondence with
the numbers 1 up to n--
then its power
set is also finite
and has cardinality 2 to the n.
And you can prove by induction,
if you like, that 2 to the n
is always bigger than n.
And so a theorem I'll
prove next time, which
will finish our discussion
of sets and cardinality,
and then we'll move on
to the real numbers,
is this theorem due
to Cantor, which
says that not just
for finite sets
do we have the power set
being, in some sense, strictly
bigger than the original
set, but for any set.
So this theorem due to
Cantor is if A is a set,
then the cardinality of
A is strictly smaller
than the cardinality
of its power set.
So this definitely
answers our question.
Does there exist a set
with cardinality bigger
than the natural numbers?
So let me write
this as a remark.
In fact, maybe I'll state
this as another theorem, which
just follows immediately
from this getting
used over and over again,
is that the cardinality
of the natural
numbers, this is less
than the cardinality
of the power
set of the natural
numbers, which is less
than the cardinality
of the power
set of the power set of
the natural numbers, right?
I can now take this as a
set and take its power set.
And I get a new set
with bigger size,
which is less than the power
set of the power set where--
how many do we have now-- of the
power set of natural numbers,
and so on.
And formally, this means there's
an infinity of infinitudes.
There's an infinite
number of infinite sizes,
one getting strictly--
in some sense, strictly
bigger than the previous size.
And maybe you're wondering--
there's one more
question that's kind
of sandwiched in between
here, pun intended, is--
let's look at this first guy.
Does there exist a set A
such that it has size bigger
than natural numbers-- so
it's uncountable-- but has
size strictly smaller
than the power
set of the natural numbers.
And this question is called
the continuum hypothesis,
hypothesis because it
is independent from one
of the standard axiomatic
treatments of set theory.
But we will not
touch this question.
This is beyond the
scope of this class,
but it's an interesting
question that's
out there that people
just don't know.